كتير قوي في حياتنا وحوالينا بقت فالصوت
غريبه قوي احنا واحده صغيرين كلنا كلنا
كنا طالعين امال ايه اللي حصل
وبصراحه
عشان مش اجابه ممكن تكون منطقيه
القطه يبقى
احنا في حد عمل لنا
جماعي او عمل حمله اعلانيه جامده قوي
اقنعنا بيها
خالص ولا ايه
مش بس كده انا كمان قلت غالبا ده كان اول
اعلان
فرصه هات لنا فرصه هات لنا منه
هات لنا فرس وهات لنا فرصه وهات لنا منه
على خير
اول التواصل مع الحيوانات دي حاجه
نعمله
لنفسي
الح
اله النفسيه الحيوانات
وكمان بتقدر نفهم اي تصرفات غريبه لها هم
دي بيعملوا تصرف فانا هاخدهم معي رحله الى
عالم الحيوان واتمنى لما نرجع
تفكروا في حياتكم ايه الحاجات الجيها اصلي
وايه الحاجات الفلس اللي اتفضلوا تغيروها
وهبت
دي
كان اول مره اصحابه كان مبسوط وبيلعب
معك
وبعد كده يعمل حاجه غريبه ما كانوش بيعمل
حاجه زي كده
جدا وخد ادويه وتعالج شويه بقتن شويه عيش
ويطلع ويرجع ينعمل كده في الاخر الوان
بصوا بقى هو
دي حاله نفسيه ومش هنقدر نعمل له حاجه
بس ما نعرفش
اين هو
حاسس بالوحده هو طول اليوم قاعد في البيت
ولما بي
رجعوا
اما ايده فاكتشفت ان هو قبل ما يجزه كان
بيقعد عند
ولد كان
طول الطريق
ان هو مفتقدهم ومفتقر حقيقيه وبعد ماما
موجودين في البيت
مش بس كده كان في مفاجاه مفاجاه بقى ان
احنا اكتشفنا ان في بنت
كوكو مش بيحبها ومش عايز يتعامل معاها انا
سالتهم مين بصوا كده وضحكوا
اسابيع وهم مستعجلين قوي عايزين يتخضوا
ويتجوزوا كل حاجه بسرعه
طب يا جماعه انا طبعا ما اقدرش اقول ما
يتجوزش بس انا باثق في احساس
فكل اللي هقدر اقوله لكم قولوا له ما
يستعجلش
[موسيقى]
اللي بيحبها
[تصفيق]
هو ابتدى يطلع وتبقى احسن مش بس كده وما
اكتشفوا انه البنت اللي كان كوكو ما
بيحبهاش
كذا ولد في نفس الوقت وكلهم
نفسيه
كم حد منا يحاسس في الوحده مع انه فرصه
اهله واصحابه في الشغل
الفرق بينه وبين كوكو ان احنا بنخبي
وبقينا التطوير قوي في ان احنا
بنخبي ساعات على نفسنا يعني ساعه تضحك على
نفسنا كل حاجه تمام
وعشان كده بنتفاجئ ان حد منا فجاه تعبئه
تعب ويكونش معاه على نفسه لجوه
وده كان اول درس اتعلمتوا ركوكه انه لو
انت عايز حاجه حقيقيه وعلاقات حقيقيه
لازم تكون صادق مع نفسك وطالع اللي جواك
ما لهاش حد تاني
احنا بنهرب منها
[تصفيق]
وعايزه ادي لغز لاول حاجه تعلمتها
بس عشان تبقى شاطر مع نفسك انت لازم تبقى
عارف نفسك لازم تبقى عارف
اللي يريحك
طب تعرف انه قياس ازاي انا بسميه حاجه
اسمها
المقياس الميه بالليل كهرباء
ده
ده الاكياس بتاعك عشان حاجه تدي له اسم
يعني
القياس بتاعكوا ايه كل واحد بيفكر بقى
المقياس
بتاع الحاجات المهمه في حياتك تاني حاجه
عامله ازاي انت حد بيحب الدوشه بيحب بسرعه
ولحد محتاج الهدوء ما بحبش الناس الحاجات
دي على طبيعتك
وثالث حاجه اللي بيخليك مش طايق
بمعنى
تنور كلنا بيبقى عندنا
كده لو عملناها بتنور
في ناس تنور
من باب الحاجات اللي بتعجبني قوي في
الحيوانات ان هو لو حاول يقول لك ان في
مشكله زي ما عمل وانت اللي استجبتش ومش
هيعادي يعني ايه هيعدي هيعلي يعني
مثلا على
فطور على فكره انا زعلانه منك وانت مخدتش
بالك
المره الجايه هتعمل لك هتعمل لك على
السجاده الشمال
غبي او على الكنبه الصالون البيضاء هي
هتفضل تعادل درجه
مالك يا حبيبي بتعمل ايه
ان اوضه تاكل الاكياس
ودي يوقع
صح بس مش في التمرين وكانه عارف ان
البطولات هي المشكله وممكن
الكلب ينط من البلكونه
زي
البلك انا
كلب ضغط من البلكونه في الدور الاولاني
نط بره لا نط
الكاس بس للاسف
كان السؤال
اللي جاوب عليه
هو بيسمع صوتك حقيقيه
وعرفت ان هو بينزل علشان كلبه في ميل
جولدن لونها بني
لو ما سالتش صاحبه لو لو في حاله
اللي قدامنا
عندهم قال لي انه دايش قدام باب اللي
عندهم
طلعت
نقط بالبلكونه عشان يروح للي هو عايزه وده
اللي تعلمته انه لو عايز على بلاطه حياه
حقيقيه لازم يكون عندك الشجاعه تروح
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
من غير شجاعه بخوف ما فيش حاجه هتحصل في
حياتك مفيش حاجه تتغير طبعا مش من
البلكونه ههه بس هاتيها
مختلفه في حياتنا
علاقه
واله
[موسيقى]
ناء
الحيوانات
كنا نشوف
شاشه الق
ياده اول مره اقابلها
تطلع
[موسيقى]
لوزه خليتني اعرف ان الحاجات الحقيقيه مش
حاسس واحنا بنبقى كلنا عارفين في
حاجه السلطان مش كان لازم اتعلمت حاجه
اتعلمت لو عايز حياه حقيقيه لازم تتصل
وتاخد خطوه حتى لو انت مش متاكد منك
ايديها ما كانتش عارفه اعمل ايه وانا لما
كنت متاكده ايه اللي
من غير ما تبقى لما تثق وتاخد الخطوه ما
فيش حاجه ممكن تتغير وده هادي له
رمز
تصل الى ربنا هيعمله
انا لما بصيت
وعايزاكم تحفظوها كويس
وانا افكر
كان وقت وقت اشتغل في شغلانه في مكان
تشتغل مع نفسك بجد انت بتواجه المجهول
بيبقى حاجه بتبقى حاسس انك خايف مش عارف
مفيش اي نوع من الاستبيان
اكتشفت ان انا مشيت على التلات حروف دول
من غير
ان انا كنت صادقه مع نفسي ولما حاجه
ندهتني غريبه زيكي رحت وراها
كان عندي الشجاعه اني اشتغل شغلانه محدش
عارفها اول حد بعملها وما حدش وناس كتير
مش فاهمها واسيب شغلانه بقالي سنين فيها
وناجحه فيها واخر حاجه دي بتعلمها تعلمتها
فلوس ودي حاجه اتعلمتها ولسه هتعلمها
لانها مش سهله خالص وده خلاني عايزه اقول
لكم ان لو اي حد عايز يعمل تغيير حقيقي في
حياته مش لاي حاجه هو مش موثوق فيها فكرت
ايه اللي مش مبسوطين فيه في الشغل في
علاقه انتم محتاجين لو عايزه حقيقي في
حياتك انت محتاج
[موسيقى]
لاهم حاجه عايزه اقولها لكم النهارده
انه اكويز انا بسميها
او معادله الحياه الحقيقيه وهي زي ايشيل
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
لو عايز تعمل تاني تقيل في حياتك هتلاقي
ان انت واقف لو انت مش مب
سوط او في علاقه هتلاقي ان واحده من
التلاته دول
ما عندكش
الشجاعه تغير او
وبعد ما وصلت
بعد ما
وصلت
في علاقه نكد عليك مؤذيه ما تضيعهاش ما
بتحبوش
وما تضيعهاش حاجه نفسك تعملها ومؤخرها
ومؤخرها ومؤخرها
انت كل مره كل يوم يبقى قدامك اختيارين
اختيارين اختياري اصلي واختي
المهم انت هتختار ايه
[تصفيق]